Merhabalar
Hoş geldiniz Öncelikle İzmir'de evinde
memleketinde olmaktan dolayı inanılmaz
mutluyum Her şeyden önce davet içinde
çok çok teşekkür ediyorum ben Doçent
Doktor Dicle 29 Aslında Davranış
Bilimleri üzerine odaklanmış fakat
birçok farklı merak ve ilgi alanı olan
bir kişiyim ve bugün son zamanlarda çok
dikkatimi çeken bir konuyla alakalı
teknolojinin özgürleştirici kapasitesi
ile alakalı olarak sohbet edelim istedim
bizim
teknolojiyi neden özgürleştirici kabul
ettiğimizi düşünmek ve buna daha detaylı
olarak bakmak için sizi biraz farklı bir
yolculukla işin içine almaya çalışmak
istiyorum
adını
verdik yaşayan en önemli kuantum
fizikçilerinden biri olan carlörü
kitabının ilk sayfalarında şöyle bir
cümleye yer veriyor
yaşayan Evren içerisinde
hiçbir varlık kendi kibirli yalnızlığı
içerisinde değildir ve bu şekilde
hareket edemez
daha sonra detaylandırıyor bu mevzuyu ve
hiçbir varlıktan kastının ne olduğunu
Açıklıyor bize Yıldız kümeleri
galaksiler
galaksilerin arasında yalan Kara Madde
kara delikler boşluklar hepsi bir
düzenin içerisine ve birbiriyle bağlantı
halinde varlıklarını sürdürüyorlar
güneş sistemi gezegenimiz güneş sistemi
ile beraber dönmekte olan galaksiler
tamamının kendi içerisinde bir dinamiği
ve bir bağlantı sağlığı var
dünyaya Eğer yüzüne inelim
yeryüzündeki bütün varlıklar birbirine
görünür görünmez bağlarla bağlantılar
ağaçlar mantarlarla mantarlar otlarla
bitkilerle haberleşiyorlar farkında
olalım ya da olmayalım insan büyük
kibreğin içerisinde bazen bunu görmüyor
ama bütün bu varlıklar kendi içerisinde
bir bağlantı sağlık halindeler
ve evrene geçelim kendi vücudumuza
geçelim vücudum
Uz için nasıl milyoneron hepsi
birbiriyle bağlantısı sağlık içerisinde
ve birbirinden ayrı hareket ettikleri
takdirde herhangi bir anlam
yaratamıyorlar
şimdi doğaya baktığımız zaman bütün bu
bağlantı sağlık silsilesinin içerisinde
çok önemli bir noktayı fark ediyoruz
beyinden bir nöronu çıkarttığınız zaman
beyin işlevlerine kaldığı yerden devam
edebiliyor Hatta belki bazılarınızı
duymuşsunuzdur inanılmaz bir uygulamalar
var bu konu ile ilgili beynin yarısını
çok Majör sorunlar sebebiyle aldırmak
durumunda kalan insanlar var yarım bir
beyinle yarım küre ile hayatlarına devam
ediyorlar bir ila 5 yıl arasında Tekrar
konuşma becerisi yürüme becerisi kazanıp
dışarıdan
bakan sıradan
bir insan beynin yarım Küresi yok emara
soktuğunuzda bir taraf bomboş Neden
Çünkü diğer taraf bütün bu bağlantı
sağlıkları yeniden inşa etmiş kurgulamış
ve dediğim gibi bir İlla 5 yıl arasında
bütün beyin ile hareket eden bir insanla
aynı insan haline dönüşebiliyor bu
insanlar bu inanılmaz bir şey
bağlantı sağlık doğanın bize öğrettiği
verdiği en önemli bilgilerden biri ve
fakat
İnsan kendi oluşturduğu sistemlerin
içerisinde de bu bağlantı sağlığı takdir
etmeye çalışmış ama bir noktaya atlamış
bugüne kadar
kurulmuş kurgulanmış olan bütün insani
sistemlerin içerisinde bu bağlantı
sağlığın içinde hareket eden birimler
bireyler üniteler
hiyerarşik bir yapı içerisinde
tabi uçarken hiyerarşik bir yapıyla
uçmuyorlar ağaçlar birbirine Hiyerarşi
bir yapı ile
bağlı değil birisi Amir birisi memur
değil birisi müdür birisi çalışan değil
Fakat insanların kurguladığı bütün
sistemlerde
bağlantısallık olmakla beraber bu
Hiyerarşi var
neden
bu çok önemli bir soru bunu düşünmemiz
gerekiyor diye düşünüyorum Çünkü bu
hiyer
Arşi kendimizi Bugünün de teması olan
cam fanusların içerisinde buluyoruz ve
zaman zaman o fanusların kenarlarına
çarpıyoruz ve canımız acıyor bu sosyal
sistemler insanların inşa etmiş olduğu
sosyal sistemler gerekli işlevi zaman
zaman göremeyebiliyorlar İnsan doğayı
taklit etmiş güzel yapılar kurgulamış
ama araya Majör ve farklılık sokarak
vurgulamış ve umaja farklılık Bizim
zaman zaman canımızı yakıyor
şimdi biraz daha geri plana geçip
dünyayı uzaktan bakıp İnsanlık tarihi
boyunca bu bağlantı sağlıkları nasıl
kurgulandığına bir bakalım istiyorum Bu
bağlılık arasında
en çok etkileyen ve insanlık tarihini en
önemli gelişimlerinden birini sağlayan
en önemli bağlantı sağlık internet
bu salondaki arkadaşlarım internetin ilk
çağı olan ve 1-0'a bazı arkadaşlarım
yetişmediler henüz Dünya üzerinde
varlıkları söz konusu değildi 2000'li
yılların başından bahsediyorum
o yıllarda Biz internetle tanıştığımızda
Aslında dünyanın en önemli bağlantı
sağlığının insan hayatına en derinden
etkileyecek bağlantısı alın içerisinde
de adım atmıştık
atsallığın içerisinde de fakat
Biraz önce bahsettiğim gibi bir Server
yapısı Yani bir Hiyerarşi yapısı
kurgulanmıştı
bütün üniteler bilgisayarlar birbirine
bağlı Fakat bu bilgisayarların
arasındaki iletişimi sağlayan bir Server
yani sunucu var bilgiler bu sunucuların
üzerinden farklı bilgisayarlara
dağılıyor Aslında internet ilk
kurgulandığında Maksat pekte bu değildi
Maksat şuydu Ben 4-5 tane bilgisayarı
birbirine bağlarım kablolarla ya da
kablosuz bağlantıyla ve bu bilgisayarlar
kendi arasında konuşur fakat iş 3
bilgisayar 5 bilgisayar 500 bilgisayar 5
milyar bilgisayar boyutuna çıktığında
artık Server yapısından başka bir şeyle
yönetilemez hale geldi ve dolayısıyla
arada Merkezi bir birim oluştu
merkeziiyet Sevgili arkadaşlarım sevgili
konuklarım benim perspektifimden bu
dünyanın başında gelmiş en büyük
lanetlerden biridir Çünkü altüst
ilişkisinin kaynağıdır merkeziyet
birilerinin hükümranlığının birilerinin
o hükümranının altında yaşamasının
kaynağıdır ve aslında
zaman
içinde sizi çok ufak internetin tarihi
üzerinde gezdirerek neden teknolojinin
özgürleştirici olabileceğine taşımak
istiyorum
ekranda gördüğünüz şu anda bizim
internetin tarihi olarak tanımladığımız
bir tablo ve 1-0 bu bahsettiğim
2000'lerin başı benim evime İlk
bilgisayar Bugün annem babam da burada
bilgisayar geldiğinde ben lise sondaydım
üniversite sınavına hazırlanıyorum
internetten uzak durmaya Çalışıyoruz
tabii belli sürelerde izimiz var o
zamanlarda ve 1-0'ın yapısı Aslında
doğadaki bağlantı sağlığa benzer
kurgulanmaya çalışılmıştı ama olmadı
neden sayı arttıkça
teknolojik mimari
bireyin eşit her bilgisayarın eşit
haklara sahip olduğu doğadaki ne benzer
bir bağlantı sağlık yapısını Kaldıramadı
Dolayısıyla bizde
Aslında
merkeziiyetsiz olan fakat Merkezi
iyileşmek zorunda kalan bir internete
uyandık
sıfırda bir de şöyle bir özellik vardı
yine genç arkadaşları bilmiyorlar o
zamanlar internete bir şey yazıp
çizemiyorduk
arkadaş sadece birilerinin yazdıklarını
okuyorduk Yani bir gazete okur gibi bir
televizyon seyreder gibi birileri bir
şey yazıyordu biz
de sonra da çetoları vesaire çıktı
chatleşmeye başladık bu demokratik bir
ortam mı Bence pek değil Neden Birileri
size bir şey veriyor Sizin sesiniz hiç
kimse tarafından duyulmuyor pek
demokratik bir falan değil Dolayısıyla
internetin yaratıcılarının
amaçladıkları noktaya pek fazla gidemedi
fakat
üst katman eklendiğinde yani ve biki 0
gündeme geldiğinde
bir sosyal medya ile tanıştık ve Benim
de sesim dünyaya ulaşmaya başladı çok
daha demokratik bir ortam çok daha
özgürleştirici bir ortam
mı acaba
ma
alesef bu şekilde de çalışmadı Çünkü
bahsettiğin gibi 5 milyar bilgisayar
kapasitesine çıktığımızda artık bu
Server yapısı Öyle bir hale gelmişti ki
merkeziyet bazı tekerlerin elinde
toplanmış Facebook yani bu günün metası
bütün sosyal medya platformları
neredeyse kontrol etmeye başlamış Bir
ülkenin bir şirketin kontrolünde olan
serverler Donald trump'ın bile sesini
kısmaya muktedir hale gelmişti
biliyorsunuz Twitter'dan hesabını
kapattı askıya aldım
Hani demokrasi Hani özgürlük Hani ben bu
amaçla uğruna interneti kurgulamış ve
Hayata geçirmiştim bir süreliğine askıda
neden aslında Çünkü Merkezi
sizin fikrinizi çeki veriyor
oradaki hayatın sona eriyor diyor ki ben
seni artık bu an içerisinde istemiyorum
Neden Çünkü birileri o Merkezi sistemin
kontrolünü eline geçirmiş durumda
istediğim internet bu değil dedi bazı
teknoloji uzmanları bu teknoloji
yaratıcı Gerçekten inanılmaz müthiş
insanlar çünkü
hayatı ele alarak bugün yaşadığımız
sistemi kırıp
karşılıklı bir sisteme geçiş yapmamızı
sağlıyorlar ve 3-0 işte böyle doğdu
Sevgili arkadaşlarım sevgili konuklarım
ve 3-0
IPS adı verilen bir teknolojinin
üzerinde yükselen yeni ve anlayışı bu ve
anlayışı blockchainden yararlanıyor ayıp
etsen yararlanıyor ve yaptığı doğadaki
bağlantı sağlığı takdir etmek yani
Hiçbir Server yapısı yok 5 milyar
bilgisayarınızda olsa 50 milyar
bilgisayarınızda olsa hiçbir Merkezi
güce ihtiyaç duymadan birbirinize
bağlanıp konuşabilecek hale geleceksiniz
Peki bu beni nasıl özgürleştirecek bir
örnek Kripto paralar Kripto para sahibi
olan Kimler var Bir bakabilir miyim
şimdi bunun finansal getirileri
götürüleriyle ilgili Konuşmayacağım ama
bahsettiğim bahsetmek istediğim şey şu
daha önce bütün finansal işlemleri
yönetme gücüne sahip olan bir imkanın
paranın kontrolü sadece Merkez
bankalarında ve devletlerde
hükümetlerdeydi
bugün geldiğimiz
nokta kontrolü Merkezi bir noktada değil
para sürme piyasaya para sürme yetkisi
becerisi bütün bu İnsanların oluşturduğu
blok zincir ağının üzerindeki
üreticilerde
Dolayısıyla Merkezi bir yapıda değil
diğer örnek bu benim çok hoşuma giden
çok önemli bulduğum bir örnek Enes
fiillerden bahsediyoruz biliyorsunuz
Elif değiller ne yapıyor Nasıl
kaldırıyor bu Merkezi yapıyor ortadan en
nefciler bir örneğin diyelim ki ben bir
ressamım ve resmimi dünyaya açmak
istiyorum bir müzayede evinde satışa
çıksın istiyorum ya da bir sergi
salonunda yer almasını sergilenmesini
istiyorum Bunun için ne yapmanız
gerekiyor biliyor musunuz bunun için
sanatçılardan sanat simsarlarında
müzayede evlerinden ve
ciddi meblağlar ödeyerek bu eserleri
evlerinde koleksiyonlarında biriktiren
koleksiyonerlerden oluşan bir Ağın
içerisinde yer almanız gerekiyor bakın
yine bir A'dan bahsediyorum Kültür Sanat
Fakat bu Ağın köşeleri tutulmuş bu ağa
dahil olabilmeniz için bir müzayede
evinde bir sergi sararı salonunda bu
sergi salonunun sahibini bir sanat
simsarını bir tüccarı tanıyor olmanız
gerekiyor bir koleksiyonları tanıyor
olmanız gerekiyor ki resminiz o salonda
sergilenebilsin
takdirde dünyanın en iyi ressam olsanız
da Van Gogh gibi yoksulluktan kimsenin
sizi tanımadığı bir şekilde dünyanın
güzel bir köşesinde hayatınızı
kaybedebilirsiniz
bu söz konusu değil
elifciği platformlarında bütün dünyaya
açabiliyorum bütün dünyanın en ünlü
koleksiyonerleri gelip oradaki eserlere
bakıyorlar Benim artık bunun için
Merkezi bir Ağın
göbeğinde durmakta olan güç sahibi
kişilere yakın olmam onların yakını
olmam gerekmiyor ben kendi çabamla
dünyaya ulaşabiliyorum inanılmaz bir
özgürlük
Bir diğer örnek biliyorsunuz 2 hafta
önce seçim sürecini kapattık dijital
demokrasi diye bir kavram yükseliyor
dijital demokrasi benim için niye önemli
bizim gibi ülkeler için özelliklerini
önemli ki Bence bütün dünya için aynı
önemli teşkil ediyor dijital Demokraside
bugünkü demokrasinin Aksine ben temsilci
seçmiyorum
ve bu temsilciler
seçildikten sonra ister istemez
kendilerini seçen insanlar da kopuk bir
hayat sürmeye başlıyorlar ve bu kopukluk
Dolayısıyla benim isteklerim Benim
taleplerim tam olarak yansımıyor ve
politikalara dönüşmüyor Dolayısıyla
aradaki bu kopukluk halkında tandaşın
aleyhine işlemeye başlıyor bir süre ama
dişi de böyle bir sorun yok Neden Çünkü
temsilciye ihtiyaç yok çünkü bu Ağın
içerisinde bazı muktedirlere gücü verip
süs ilişkisine girmek zorunda değilsiniz
her kararı ben kendim alabiliyorum
mecliste yapılacak olan her oylamaya Ben
vatandaş olarak kendini dijital bir
şekilde katılıp el kaldırabiliyorum bir
vekil gibi vekile ihtiyacım yok
Dolayısıyla üstünde duracak biri
olmayacak Bana buyruk verecek Emir
verecek biri olmayacak doğrudan kendi
kararlarımızı kendimizin alabildiği
gerçek bir demokrasiye geçiş yapmış
olacağız
özgürleştirici mi bence gayet
Bizim bugün bu devrimleri
konuşabilmemizin sebebi Aslında blok
zincir teknolojisi ve bu teknoloji her
gün katlanarak büyümeye devam ediyor bu
teknolojinin en özgürleştirici
yanlarından bir tanesi de
sizler gibi gençlerin bu teknolojiyle
iştigal ederek mesleklerini bambaşka
şekillere dönüştürmeleri
hiyerarşinin dışına çıkartabiliyorsunuz
Arkadaşlar artık bugün mesleki olarak
elde ettiğimiz başarı etmek istediğiniz
başarı birilerinin tekiyle altında olmak
durumunda değil bu teknolojilerle Aşina
alarak haşır neşir olarak işinize
Entegre ederek işinizi bambaşka bir
boyuta getirip adınızı dünyaya bizzat
duyma şansınız var bunun için hiçbir
muktedirin koltuğu altında olmanıza
gerek yok işte bu yüzden Özgür
leştirir ve size Özellikle bu
merkeziyetsizlik teknolojileri ile
ilgili uzun uzun çalışmanızı tavsiye
ediyorum avukat da olacak olsanız Doktor
da olacak olsanız öğretim üyesi de
olacak olsanız hangi mesleği yaparsanız
yapın geleceğin burada yaptığını
bilmenizi istiyorum çünkü bütün dünya
teknolojiyi elinde tutanlar
geliştirenler bu dünyayı şekillendiren
insanlar şu anda bu teknoloji üzerinde
çalışıyorlar neden yıllardır
çeperlerine çarpıp durduğumuz bu cam
fanuslardan bıktık
Doğa özgürdür
insanlar da doğarken
özgürlük insanlar
kurgulamak istedikleri sistemleri
yaratırken bugünkü modern toplumu
yaratırken doğadaki bağlantısallık
ağlarından koparak kendi gerçeklikleri
ve egoları ne kibirleri karlovelli'ye
geri dönüyorum kibirli yalnızlıkları
yüzünden hiyerarşik sistemler inşa edip
bağlantısallığı bunun üzerinden
sağlamaya çalıştılar
bizi o cam fanuslara kapattı bugün
yapabildiğimiz sıkıldığımız bir cam
fanusta bir balık gibi başka bir camfanu
bilmekten ibaret Bu şirket benim için
çok iyi yararsın başka bir yer arşive
kadar yoktu Dolayısıyla Biz başını sağa
sola çarpan balıklar gibi o fanusların
içerisinde
vaziyetteydik Fakat artık elimizde çok
çok önemli bir çekiç var
bu çekiç insanın Yıldızlar gibi ağaçlar
gibi kendi beynindeki nöronlar gibi
doğasıyla barışık bir vaziyette doğasına
uygun bağlantısal ama hiyerarşik olmayan
bir yapı içerisinde
özgürleşebilmesine imkan veriyor mesele
şu
çekicin farkında mısınız
çekici kullanmaya Hazır mısınız
çok teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]